on this episode we talk about impatient
clients rupiah and what I would do if I
was running for president of the United
States of America you ask questions and
I answer them
this is the askgaryvee show
hey everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 94 of the ask gary
vee show uh it's Liz's birthday it's my
wife's birthday happy birthday darling I
love you
I'll be leaving here shortly and coming
to hang yeah really excited super pumped
for episode 100 on May 18th in New York
City at 4:30 p.m.
RSVP up actually question of the day
are you coming and if not why and India
let's get into show India the show
yeah but the 590 yes India is like if
you read the comments there's like 400
saying yes I just said yes to like
follow along so I really need to get a
count vaynernation I might have 500 just
from that Thomas asks what do you think
is more important in business IQ or EQ
Jesus I'm showing some real Tom Selleck
stuff here you could have warned me
Mossad segoe is like seriously weird who
asked that Thomas I I'm making
scratchies am I making scratches Rick
you're not you know you don't get to
edit this either making scratches for
you all right who Thomas by the way the
black and white version of this show is
way better than the stuff that goes in
color
Thomas I think it's massively important
for the entrepreneur or CEO or leader to
be self-aware the answer to your
question is both it's about doubling
down on your strengths for me thank you
you know I actually think I'm an IQ
below average and I think that I'm an EQ
all time great and thus I go all in on
EQ and that is building the foundation
of my success it allows me to give back
to my community in a way that I
most people in my position today don't
which I think builds me leverage it
allows me to build a culture here and
just a lot of different variables and so
I bet on that it allows me to have
instantaneous relationships and so I
tripled down and put myself in a
position to be EQ but there's plenty of
people who win on just quanta data
there's a lot of people who are watching
the show right now that are just sitting
in their in their room by themselves
running math and and data and and
building tech and that's what they like
they don't want to jam with anybody else
that I'm gonna be bothered by anybody
else and they'll make millions and
billions and hundreds of millions or
tens of thousands but be happy and so I
think the key is self-awareness the
answer is both the real answer is to
figure out which one are you and by the
way most people aren't ninety ten or
eighty twenty like I probably am most
people fall into fifty five forty five
60/40 70/30 but you know plenty of
people fall on the other categories try
to get to a place where you understand
yourself and understand what your
strengths are too many people try to be
like me because it's sizzling and it's
sexy and people want to be charismatic
and on stage and and then there's plenty
of people like me that wishes I mean I
wish my math skills were as strong as a
J on the spot where I can make some
other business decisions where I don't
have to hedge and so you know we've all
got something and you just need to
accept what's yours and go in on that so
the answer to a question is both it's
just individually different depending on
the person yeah nice yes it is right
make a note Sivan don't forget we're in
go mental okay who I almost had a
disaster by the way there's fear I think
there was fear on that video you know
what replay that d-roc slowdown the fear
the fear part there was fear I know I
know they saw it
chef Lizette asks what's the biggest
mistake you see people making in social
media is there something you've seen
that impresses you chef
it's great to have you back in the show
I like how you're leading the question I
know you want me to say something about
the vaynernation on meerkat but I won't
do that for you so I haven't seen
anything that's impressed me because I'm
not paying attention to anybody so I
have no idea as far as what are people
doing wrong equally I've been so head
down over the last four to five months
I've not been paying close attention my
intuition is that people are still doing
a very bad job on Twitter I see nothing
but right hooks on Facebook I see very
bland non contextual non targeted
content you know I think people are I
think Instagram has probably been the
place where there's been the most
innovation people are trying a lot of
different things because it's scale I
think snapchat saw some people putting
together some great stories so I think
the cool stuffs happening on Instagram
and snapchat which is too bad because
Facebook is still the juggernaut
I think Pinterest loaded pins I've been
seeing some really interesting stuff
faithbox and incubated company here
Willie's been hitting some pay dirt
there I'm really impressed with him it's
a little humble brag of our own thing
but I apologize the only things I'm
paying attention to truth is I'm just
not paying attention enough because I
don't need to because I know exactly
what to do and that's what I'm focusing
on and and that's that take that Luke
asks you've repeatedly mentioned your
love of root beer over the years
why root beer specifically any we should
give a world you know I grew up a huge
root beer fan either the the flavor just
hit me right you know I grew up drinking
coke and root beer heavily really grew
up on soda which is what why it was so
hard to siphon off of it that's crazy
I'm about to hit a one-year mark of not
drinking any soda which is insane to me
uh yeah I actually pulled up a list
because I wasn't recalling what what I
loved but here are some of the ones I
mean Henry wine hearts is incredible
like just incredible root beer I'm also
a very very very big fan or is it here
already forgot of a Hosmer Mountain big
fan of that it's in Connecticut you were
shaking it you know that I got it cool
pirate
kay grew beer which is in Rochester love
that huge fan
Thomas Kemper I've drank a lot of that
root beer huge huge of a huge fan of
that
Virgil's is a good one that I think a
lot of people can find but more like an
entry level out of that group and you
know that's it so there's a couple of
root beers for you guys to try as a
matter fact the side question will have
several this episode in Facebook and and
YouTube what is your favorite root beer
if you love root beer uh yeah I think
about repair the way I think about wine
actually Shaitaan asks what's the best
way to deal with my patient clients she
kind of hope I'm pronouncing that right
shat on you know I'm gonna say something
pretty interesting I have pretty extreme
views on this question meaning I think
the answer to the question is brute
force
I never waver ever ever you know when a
client's pushing back and they're like
well this isn't gonna work I push back
equally with ten percent more gusto in
the other direction which is it works I
see it work all the time I see work for
myself I see it work for my clients I
see it work for other people and you're
just not doing it right
we haven't had enough time to pull it
off yet blah blah blah
so unwavering and then number two equal
with my unwavering I just don't give a
crap if they fire us or give up I just
don't I know how this is gonna play out
I love being on the right side of
history and I'm willing to give up my
short term money for the long term I
told you so sucker let me just say that
again and this is what makes me a happy
person with clients is why I can do
client services I am willing to give up
my short term money for my long term I
told you so sucker and that's it so I
win either way I win if I'm able to
forcefully convince them to stay the
course I keep my monies I win if they
say get out of here you're fired because
I'm gonna see them on the street in
three years and be like now what Punk
and I love that feeling I like that more
than the money actually thus it's all
good for me
Shabbat asks what advice would you give
for candidates running for president on
how to utilize social media for their
campaign sure about I think the most
intriguing thing to me and I don't know
if it will ever happen but I think when
it happens I'll be like damn if I was
born in America that would have been me
because truth is if I was born in
America I would 100% be a politician and
we tried to become the president the
United States but because I wasn't and I
can't be President I'm selfish and the
fact that I can't be the top dog makes
the game completely not interesting [ __ ]
being in a governor and so anyway I did
to do what I would do is go rogue as
rogue I would come out the gate throw
every skeleton I've got out there all of
them I mean I don't care what the person
does you know if that person did drugs
cheated on their wife or husband stole
money punched someone stabbed someone
like all of it all of it all of it from
the get get it out of the way cuz it's
mo against the thing that I want that
person to do which is then go
transparent as hell right like like
throw it all out there leave nothing for
your competitor to dig up on you because
you've now taken control of it by
throwing it out there you may dip people
may not want to vote for you but then
you start building momentum from that
bottom spot and you start going in the
direction of pure meerkat periscope pure
content at scale pure Q&A sessions all
day every day pure and utter
transparency in a world where you've
created the leverage by throwing every
skeleton I mean all of them not I mean
the ones you're okay with you're okay
maybe saying you cheated on your spouse
or you did drugs or you stole cash but
you feel bad that you punched your mom
but then that's a mo you've got to let
it all out all of it all of it is the
punch of money for you yeah okay cool uh
you've got to go all out and then what
you've done by doing that is you've
created leverage on the other side for
you to be able to be as transparent and
then what happens is really interesting
then what you have is momentum in the
other direction because you've been
transparent with America but your
competition and competitor have
now you're at the debate and saying what
am i used to fun you know it's kind of
you know what it is oh my god you know
what it is it's literally Eminem's last
battle in a mile that's exactly that's
literal it just hit me look at it I was
just because we talked about hip-hop
like I was it's like I was about to say
but I know something about [ __ ] like
that's really what it is
I actually think so my advice is the way
Eminem won the last battle in 8-mile the
movie is the way I think a politician
can revolutionize politics in America as
a matter of fact before I die I think
that will happen because I think
technology will push us into a corner of
not allowing just the shadows of society
to exist you know it's crazy the way I
live my life now I would be a totally
different person if I wasn't so
self-aware of what's going on with
technology I'd be a worse moral person
by just would and it's you know and
nobody's perfect but it's crazy to me
that I'm a better man because I'm scared
that somebody's gonna meerkat it tweet
it Instagram and see me out doing this
that the other thing it's just the way
it is and so that was funny pretty cool
that's what I would do
it's it I thought this was a great show
I feel this is a great great show I'm
gonna give Lizzie and her birthday all
the credit questions of the day we
talked about coming if not why
root beer list them momentum is in the
air vaynernation I'm around in New York
quite a bit in the month of May we've
banged out three shows this week we're
banging out the rest of the shows this
week and next week and a lot of the
following and then follow me I mean
we're here get ready for this momentum
are you ready for the Vayner tide you
keep asking questions I'll keep
answering them
you